this will not be a war of heroes which  is all to see this is going to be fun  the world burns you have no idea of what  men are capable of we must do something  I know you want to fight  but there are other ways of doing your  duty you're going to need a suit come on  we are the first independent  intelligence agency preserving peace and  protecting life welcome to the club  [Music]  like witches at black masses while  government's wait for orders our people  take action  mine's at blood destruction now it's  time to shut a lot  captain structure  my  [Music]  our enemies think we are gentlemen  but reputation is what people think of  you  character is what you are  I'm ready yes  [Music]  but ready we shall see  this is called a parachute it means that  one can jump out of a plane safely  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you